I want to give you the best thing to do
if you have pain or inflammation or
you're on some type of coccy2 inhibitor
or some other pain medication so first
let's talk about what cox-2 means okay
this is an immune response whether it's
in response to an injury for a healing
response
or it's to attack a microbe to kill it
and so they created these cox2
Inhibitors that block that inflammation
and a lot of people take them from Pain
a lot of people take way too many of
these medications and they have a lot of
side effects inflammation
typically when it starts is actually a
good thing but the problem is when the
inflammation is not appropriate anymore
and it's become chronic but that's when
we need to get rid of it because this
inflammation can literally dissolve your
bones destroy your joints create massive
degeneration within the body and also
cancer tends to follow into areas of
inflammation so typically people take
for a cox2 inhibitor Tylenol or aspirin
or even biox which was taken off the
market before I get into what I think is
one of the best natural cox2 Inhibitors
I want to just briefly mention this one
topic which is your genetics fairly
recently they've discovered genetic
weaknesses for inflammation and pain and
so I listed a whole series of genes that
if you have a specific problem with
these genes you may if the triggers are
there have more pain more inflammation
than someone who doesn't have a problem
with these and the reason I'm even
bringing this up is because I had a DNA
evaluation and apparently that is my my
weakness I have a lot of problems with
the genes that I'm showing you right now
so for example if I over exercise for
example or do the wrong type of exercise
I will just end up with inflammation for
a long period of time if I have some
dental work the inflammation will linger
for a lot longer if my diet is not right
now it is but in the past it wasn't
right I will just fill up with
inflammation which explains all the
inflammation I had through my spine
through my hands when I was in my 20s
and early 30s so these are genetic
problems that you need to be aware of
because you can do something about them
and I'm going to give you a whole list
of generally what you can do to keep
these genes off okay so they're not
excessively reducing too much
information so you don't necessarily at
this point need to go get a test I'm
just going to show you what to do and
they're triggered by various things
we'll talk about that but let's first
cover the main topic that I promise I
would talk about which is the best
natural cox2 inhibitor that I think can
help you with your pain or inflammation
and it relates to aspirin the way they
discovered aspirin is through a natural
plant called willow bark they isolated a
certain compound of willowbar which is a
very potent cox2 inhibitor okay an
anti-inflammatory an anti-pane
anti-fever and this compound is called
salicylic acid but what's interesting
about willibark you might just think you
could just take some willow bark and
take a little bit and it should just get
rid of your pain and it might now the
question is if aspirin was created from
willow bark why don't doctor just
recommend willibar
um well there's not a lot of money in it
and of course it's not going to be
studied because you can't necessarily
patent it and so they're not going to
promote it if you have something that's
synthetically made by a certain plant
compound you can you know control the
dosage and sell it for a lot of money
the problem with Aspirin is it comes
with a package it has side effects it
destroys the mucosal lining in your GI
system it has been known to cause ulcers
and bleeding and thin your blood but
well bark doesn't do any of that it
won't alter the mucous lining in your
gut it won't thin your blood it has very
minor side effects if any you don't get
a lot of the salicylic acid okay you get
byproducts of that which are not
necessarily even the reason why you're
going to get rid of inflammation these
phytonutrients are just amazing you have
flavonoids you have polyphenols that
have various properties to get rid of
pain now in the studies that I'm going
to talk about which I'm going to list
down below you're going to need between
120 to 240 milligrams okay in order for
it to work and sometimes you may need to
take it for several days up to a week to
see the effects but just to remind you
there's going to be no effect on blood
thinning or blood clotting there's no
change in the GI mucous layer and with
these other compounds because we're
dealing with a complex of many different
things we're not just dealing with one
isolated Factor you can get a nice
inhibition of Cox 1 and cox-2 and many
other effects as well there's something
else called five locks you can inhibit
that apparently these compounds in
willow bark also modulate or regulate
these other cytokines like IL one six
eight and ten as well as creating a
decrease of other things that create
inflammation like the tumor necrosis
factor and the NF Kappa B these are just
things that create more inflammation
will a bark can inhibit or help modulate
all of those factors in one study it was
shown that willibark was as effective in
reducing inflammation as aspirin I mean
to me that's very surprising that this
information is not broadly promoted of
course I know why but I think you need
to know about it also does other things
it helps to reduce white blood cell
reactions and it has a potent effect of
lowering cytokines which are those
things that create inflammation now
sometimes you have to increase the dose
and take it for a little bit longer but
it has virtually no side effects unless
you have an allergy to it and you can
also take willibark for gout as well
which is a big problem for many people
but now let's talk about some other
things you can do if you potentially
have some type of Gene issue now again
just because your genes are altered
doesn't mean you're going to have more
inflammation or pain especially if you
don't have the triggers like you've
never been injured you don't experience
stress you never have any losses in your
life your diet's perfect you have no
nutritional deficiencies and you've
never taken an antibiotic so that being
said I don't think we're going to find
anyone in that situation personally I've
had so many old injuries I mean just
crazy amount of injuries I've been under
massive stress my diet has sucked for
well over half of my life I've had many
many doses of antibiotics so these are
some things that I would recommend to do
generally speaking okay make sure that
you have enough omega-3 fatty acids and
at the same time you must avoid the
omega-6 fatty acids I have a lot of
videos on this but the cod liver oil is
a really good omega-3 fatty acids
because it gives you vitamin d and
vitamin A as well but sometimes you have
to take omega 3 for a good amount of
time if you're very deficient so it
could take months but potentially even a
few years if you are very very deficient
to replenish the omega-3 fatty acids and
get this ratio back in check now the
second most important thing is this
vitamin D I've done videos on this and a
small amount of vitamin D especially if
you have a genetic problem is not going
to cut it you need at least 10
000 20
000 30
000 international units or even more for
some people because out of all the
natural nutrients vitamin D is the most
potent
anti-inflammatory and anti-pain
especially if you have lower back pain
or any type of chronic pain or chronic
inflammation that comes from autoimmune
diseases going on a low carb is very
very important too because the more
carbs you have in the diet the more
inflammation you are going to have doing
moderate exercise okay not over training
Tai Chi is good yoga is great anything
low intensity aquatic exercises are
really good too magnesium is another
important remedy but you can get that in
consuming a good amount of vegetables
the vegetables alone have all sorts of
anti-inflammatory phytonutrients then we
have this genetic problem of methylation
which I'm not going to get into in this
video but just realize that if you have
a problem with methylation you are going
to have more inflammation you won't be
able to detoxify you might be depressed
and so this can be easily prevented if
you take folate methylcobolamine which
is a B12 and you take choline and you
take B1 the natural version not the
synthetic versions it can greatly assist
in your Gene
and make them work right so you can
eliminate inflammation and pain and a
lot of other problems regular
intermittent fasting and periodic
prolonged fasting Dynamite for
inflammation and pain I mean if you just
did that alone you'd probably completely
get rid of your pain why because all
these Pro survival genetics enzymes kick
in when you stop eating I mean it's just
quite remarkable your immune system
starts getting really really
strong infrared is a great therapy you
can get all sorts of infrared therapy
type pads or lasers that have a huge
effect on pain and it will also increase
melatonin which will help you
systemically with many other problems
including sleeping probiotics okay very
important especially for pain a lot of
people have inflammation because their
gut isn't right and I'm talking about
the microbiome getting more diversity in
your microbes can greatly drop
inflammation a lot of times down to zero
and of course you're going to have to
avoid certain things that are irritating
your colon like gluten and Grains but
a probiotic can greatly help you cold
water therapy whether it's a cold shower
or an ice bath or a cryotherapy I did a
video on this topic and I talked about
if you have an acute injury and you
apply it cold that might not be the best
action because you're getting rid of the
healing response but if that
inflammation is turned chronic it's
inappropriate cold therapy is a good
thing cold shower
it might be very uncomfortable but if
you have a B1 deficiency your tolerance
for cold
goes way way way down so you might need
B1 so you can get enough nerve up to
take that cold shower but it can greatly
help inflammation and of course the
other obvious thing is avoiding alcohol
smoking things like that just as a side
note there are many many natural
remedies that are cox-2 Inhibitors okay
like turmeric for example but turmeric
also
does a lot of other things too it can
act in a similar mechanism to cortisol
without the sound effects in one study
it was shown that the active ingredient
in turmeric curcumin was as effective as
another anti-inflammatory called phenol
butazone which if I'm not mistaken
that's taken off the market in the U.S
and the UK bromelain is that enzyme in
pineapple that also can greatly help you
with inflammation it's a natural
anti-inflammatory it's also really good
for sinus congestion another one
boswellia is a great cox2 inhibitor that
too can mimic steroids but without the
side effects now I've done videos on
some really amazing things you can do
for pain as well that just use
acupressure and if you have not seen my
videos on that you have to check this
out I put this video up right here